Before you call the cops, I just want you to know,...
...the first thing that I did when I woke up this morning was yell at my alarm clock.
My parents were raised in the South.
They raised me in Las Vegas.
That city still has my heart.
I hate spiders.
I'm a vegetarian.
I'm not proud about it.
I've done goat yoga.
I'm really not proud about that.
I can tell you every single word off the NWA "Straight Outta Compton" album.
I can also sing you every single word from 'Oklahoma.'
Bananas are disgusting.
I am a Christian.
I spend almost every Sunday morning teaching kids in Sunday school.
I am often asked if I am Muslim.
I'm ok with that.
I'm pretty much convinced if you met my mother, you'd automatically become a better person.
My father is a veteran.
He taught me how to say "Yes, sir" and "Yes, ma'am" to everyone that I meet.
I don't hate our president.
I pray for him.
I love basketball and also hockey.
This is my brother, James.
This is my brother, Mike.
This is my brother, John,...
...and this is my brother, Rob.
I've never been to jail.
I've never owned a gun.
I hate that anyone at all might possibly be afraid of me.
I'd go around the world and back again if I knew that single act might make your day better.
I'm a proud man.
I'm a proud black man.
Does any of this really matter?
No.
I just wanted you to get to know me better before you call the cops.